so I'm sitting there down at EA Redwood
Shores playing the battlefield hardline
beta and I'm laughing a dude just ran me
over
and in the killcam he's going down the
road buffing
[Music]
and it hit me I'm having fun playing
battlefield again I honestly haven't
felt that way since three ended the
first thing that you should know about
hard lines multiplayer is that it
doesn't take itself too seriously it's
not a tactical sim the deficit visceral
sat down with battlefield 4 and said how
do we make this more focused how do we
make this better big improvements on
modes map design general UI bullet
feedback and here's the kicker class
rebalancing makes hardline a game that
I'm looking forward to fair warning
hardline caters more towards the bad
company crowd than the old battlefield -
open skies and Jets folks who may have
to wait for battlefield 5 or this year
Star Wars Battlefront in order to get
that experience the first class is the
mechanic aka the engineer visceral has
snip the tip of this class by taking
away the RPG but fear not the mechanic
is now a close-quarters badass the
mechanic now wields the satellite phone
recons
old spawn beacon and armored insert to
take more damage and the assaults bolt
m320 high-explosive grenade launcher the
mechanic can still rek Mia calls just
for much closer ranges these changes are
important because the car chases must
flow in order for hardline to be as fun
as it can be additionally the whole SMG
class has seen a huge damage boost to
close range in order to defeat ARS but
this has been offset with some pretty
steep damage drop-off so don't try those
open street battles with the engineer
you know like the ones you saw in heat
the engineers repair torch returns in a
big way and Hotwire mode in which
players must grab vehicles and keep them
moving at high rates of speed in order
to earn capture points the repair torch
is important because working cars are
kind of the entire thing worried about
smg's now then grab the enforcer old
battlefield support class a shotgun add
eagle a riot shield a gas mask and some
tear gas will let you swat down those
smug mechanics the enforcer still has
high-caliber rifles but with limited
magazines as LMGs are now battle pickups
why you might ask
stay with me now the car chases they
must have flow the enforcer seems very
adept at high smoke able to clear Bank
interiors
and then hold out at random extraction
points with the loot using a riot shield
in order to buy enough time to get the
money to the chopper don't forget you
can now take a moment for sir without
having to request a drop just City next
step is the professional old
battlefields recon now spawn beacon
lists but more of a designated marksman
than ever being the only class with
access to DMR's and both action rifles
means the professional can shut down
lanes such as the outside of the bank
job map in high smooth if someone sneaks
up on a professional tripmines and some
nasty close range weapons like the tech
9 and mac-10 are savi at point defense
the weakness of the professional class
is mid range so get very near or very
far on a side note the DMR is excellent
at shooting down helicopters and there
are no more pesky jets to worry about
finally there's the operator formerly
assault this class lost its grenade
launcher but retains the ability to
revive heal and in some cases sell
provide after the last beta visceral has
tweaked the syringe so that operators
can only self a vibe after being rode
killed we're dying in an explosive
manner access to the assault rifle and
carbine classes make the operator most
deadly at mid range that's a quick
rundown of the new rebalance classes in
battlefield hardline beta out February
3rd
don't forget to equip your hot-pink ammo
if you earn it because it's actually a
real thing and if that doesn't scare the
SH you nothing ever will